The Thank you. Vielen Dank an das Filmorchester Prag für dieses tolle Intro. Am Diregendenpult heute Daniel Zwei. Vielen Dank für diese exklusierte Komposition, die uns, ja, die durchaus fordernd ist als Intro. Also es ist ein bisschen episches Intro, als käme jetzt die grosse Ansprache, aber nee, nur wir beiden. Nee, sind mal wieder nur wir beiden, wie ihr es kennt, wie ihr es ja mögt vielleicht auch oder hassen gelernt habt, wie dem auch sei. Oder ihr könnt eure Emotionen gut unterdrücken beim Gehören dieser Folge. You're so excited, so you just, you can can hide it i can hide it very well i can hide it too i'm not very very good in showing my emotions doch yes doch naja doch i can ich mache das also ich glaube was ich gespielt bekommen dass ich sehr offen meine emotionen von meiner emotion von mir her trage ist wie jetzt hätte ich ein display auf der Stirn, auf der steht, sauer, traurig, auch nur so ganz wenige, fünf oder so, wie so ein Furby. Ich glaube, du hast vor allem eins, du hast, glaube ich, primär Verachtung. Du bist sehr gut in Verachtung ausdrücken, das ist deine Go-To-Emotion. Und das ist so, wenn du so ein Rollenspiel spielst und du kannst dich so spezialisieren auf gewisse Fähigkeiten, du hast 90 % deiner Skillpunkte in Verachtung gepackt.
Verachtung hast du schnell zur Hand, kostet dich kaum noch Mana, kaum noch Ressourcen,
ganz schnelle Abklingenzeit, hast du sofort wieder …
Ja, aber der unsobbarische Charakter aller Zeiten offensichtlich.
Naja, aber sehr effizient im Abwehren von kleinen Gefahren.
Dann sagst du, wollen wir nicht mal in Werdepark gehen?
Ach, so das hast du auf Hotkey, du hast … ach, hast du auf Hotkey,, so auf der Maustaste, du hast es auf der linken Maustaste direkt so, ach. Tanzen, hinsetzen und, ach, ach, ach, ja, ja, nee, weiß ich nicht, ich habe auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, wie so ein Display auf der Stirn, wie so ein, was man sich so kaufen kann bei Toys R Us, diese Dinger, wo man sagt, wow, das ist ja ein Kuscheltier, was auch sich ein bisschen bewegen kann und Emotionen zeigen kann. Hat aber nur fünf Emotionen und so. Schnelles Augenklappern, leichtes Augenklappern. Ja, reicht aber, um durchzukommen beim Kind erst mal. Ich sag mal, fünfjährige haben mit mehreren Emotionen eine Menge Spaß, die denken, okay, da sind die ganze Bandbreite der Emotionen abgebildet. Bei Erwachsenen wird es schwierig, da stosse ich mit meinen fünf Emotionchen an meine Grenzen. Ja, nee, ich bin sehr offen. Aber es gibt ja noch unerforschte Emotionen. Also es gibt ja noch Emotionen, die man noch nicht entdeckt hat. Die man noch nicht entdeckt hat. Umagi, diesen Geschmack, den man noch nicht entdeckt hat, gibt es auch noch Emotionen, die man entdeckt hat. Wie heißt er nicht Magi? Umagi. Umami. Umamo. Du hast dich wieder von der Magi-Industrie verleiten, also von deren billigen Werbe-Jingles. Es heißt nicht Umagi. Nee. Das ist sehr clever eingetrichtet geworden. Umagi, lecker, lecker, lecker, lecker, Maggi. Nein, nein, nein, nein, Umami. Aber es gibt ja eine Emotion, die neu entdeckt wurde von so einem Anthropologen, der war bei irgendeinem Stamm und er hat da eine Emotion gelernt, die er nicht kannte. Die Leute haben immer über diese Emotion gesprochen, haben wir doch auch schon darüber gesprochen, Legget. Legget. Keine Erinnerung mehr an das Gespräch. Ich glaube, so hieß sogar mal eine Folge. Wir sind an dem Punkt, wo wir einfach Sachen nochmal neu machen können. Der war zu unserem Stamm und die haben von Legget gesprochen, dass sie das verspüren würden. Und er wusste mal nicht, bin ich komplett bescheuert? Ja, es ist ja schwer zu erklären.
Erklär jemandem mal eine Emotion.
Und er dachte mir, das ist ein Übersetzungsfehler, das raffe ich nicht oder so.
Und ich glaube, die haben immer so Leute vom Klippen geworfen.
Und dann haben die gesagt, das ist Legget irgendwie, das ist richtig, das Legget.
Ja, ein bisschen die Bungee springen oder was?
Nee, halt schon.
Adrenalinrausch.
Aber irgendwie so, es ist so eine Art von Rache-Gefühl, so Rache-Lust, das sich dann aber irgendwie in was Positives auflöst. Wahnsinnig positiv, jemand von der Klippe zu werfen. Ganz merkwürdig. Ja, ja. Und irgendwann hat der, das war das Interessante, irgendwann hat der Anthropologe gemeint, er fängt an, das auch selber zu spüren, als neues Gefühl. Also nicht so, ah, ich check, was die meinen und fühl's mit meinen Emotionen, sondern ich fühle dieses neue Gefühl.
Wie wenn du eine neue Sprache sprichst und plötzlich Wörter benutzt, die es in deiner Sprache nicht gibt.
Genau, ja.
Was ja auch interessant ist. Was im Deutschen aber, glaube ich, gerade wenn man die klassischen gängigen Sprachen lernt, wie du jetzt Französisch oder Englisch oder sowas, glaube ich, hast du das im Leben nicht so oft.
Wohingegen, wenn ich mit Amerikanern spreche, die Deutsch lernen, die haben das sehr häufig. Also sowas wie Mitgefühl, Mitleid, dass man dann da so sehr konkret werden kann, es da zwei Wörter für gibt, quasi das Mitleid, wo es Leiden drinsteckt, man leidet mit einem anderen mit, das ist ein anderes Mitgefühl, was positiv war. In anderen Sprachen gibt es nur das Wort Mitleid zum Beispiel. Und es ist immer negativ konnotiert, deswegen. Und dann kannst du gar nicht Mitgefühl ausdrücken. Das ist dann deren Wort für Mitgefühl auch, wogegen wir im Deutschen noch das Wort für Mitgefühl haben, was ja positiv konnotiert ist, aber Mitleid ist immer automatisch, du leidest mit dem anderen, ich habe keinen Bock auf Mitgefühl in dem Sinne.
Kann man nicht eine Sprache lernen, die nur positive Wörter hat, wo man Negatives gar nicht ausdrücken kann, wo man sagt, meine Tante ist gestorben, habe ich kein Wort für.
Trauer kenne ich nicht, ah fuck, ich habe nur Party, Party, Party, Dance, Buffet, 17 Wörter
für Buffet, 13 für Dancefloor, aber keine für Grab.
Das ist nicht mehr wie Eskimos, 18 Wörter für Schnee, keines für Probleme. Steuern, was ist das? Die Eskimos haben es ja clever gemacht, die haben 50 Inuit, haben 50 Wörter für Schnee, kein Wort für Kälte. Deswegen frieren die nicht, flohen sie, deswegen frieren die nicht. Ach so, deswegen kommt da so ein Forscher und meint, ist euch nicht kalt? Und direkt, ja scheiße, jetzt haben wir ein Wort dafür. Aber das Problem für diesen Forscher war, der ist dann irgendwann wieder zurückgekehrt zu seiner Heimat, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Wir haben angefangen Leute von Klippen zu werfen. Genau. Gott sei Dank gab es keine Klippen, sondern nur kleine Hügelchen. Richtig, der hatte Sehnsucht nach Legget, aber konnte das nicht mehr ausleben und der war dann unglücklich. Legget klingt aber auch nicht nach einem Wort, was das perfekt beschreibt. Ja, aber ich finde, jedes neue Wort muss erst mal fremd klingen. Das ist ja das Problem, wenn du neue Wörter erfindest für so ein Fantasy-Universum, bist du direkt immer, ja das klingt ja wie. So, du sagst jetzt Mordor, ja das klingt halt wie mehr Türen, so Mordors. So, klingt das nicht albern, wenn da die Feinde leben und Tolkien sagt, nee, das hören die nicht, die Leute, die hören Mordor. Es gibt aber, ja, ich finde auch das ausgedachte Namen immer schlecht klingen. Also ich habe das Gefühl, gerade wenn man so ZDF abends mal guckt oder so, Bergdoktor oder sowas, und dann kommt dann Frau Eichenfeld um die Ecke. Jedes Mal denke ich mir, das ist kein Name, niemand heißt so. Deswegen finde ich immer gar nicht so schlecht, bei den gängigen Namen zu bleiben. Wobei es ja eigentlich auch Quatsch ist. Also gerade, ich finde auch gerade die Kombination Vorname und Nachname funktioniert oft nicht in solchen Serien oder Filmen. Aber es ist ja völlig perfil, weil Namen sind ja ausgedacht. Also Vorname, Nachname kommen ja so, sind ja immer per Definition ausgedacht. Das heißt, eigentlich dürfte man das gar nicht merken, aber ich habe das Gefühl, man merkt es immer. Ja, was ich manchmal kriege, ist eine Nachricht von erwartenden Eltern, die sich einen Namen überlegen für ihr Kind und die dann sagen so, ja, wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel auch über den Namen Florentin nachgedacht. Kannst du den Namen empfehlen? Ja, du bist der schlechteste Mensch, der Name ist. Naja, ich habe jetzt nicht. I dealt with this shit for like 30 years. Hat es mich hart gemacht, wer weiß. Also ich kann es nicht bewerten, weil man hat nur einen Namen. Ich kenne einen Florentin und den finde ich lustig, der ist erfolgreich. Der ist auch? Ja, das bist du. Aber niemand kann selber seinen eigenen Namen bewerten, niemand kann sagen, würdest du Stefan empfehlen? Steff? Steff? Das abkürzen, oder? Nee, Steff, ja, Stefan, nee, ich will ja primär, ich verfolge auch die Agenda, dass ich weniger Stefan, so auf dem, das Nervigste ist ja, wenn sehr viele Leute deinen Namen tragen. Ja. Deswegen, Stefan ist okay, in meiner Generation finde ich es okay und abwärts und jünger, weil niemand heißt da so und irgendwie ist es ein Name der, ich behaupte ja wirklich, dass das Fun da drin Spaß versprüht, weil das Gehirn denkt, das ist ja wie diese Uhren, alle Uhren werden ja verkauft oder Werbung für Uhren ist immer, das sind Zeige immer auf zehn nach zehn, Entschuldigung, zehn nach zehn. Warum? Weil es so aussieht wie ein lachender Mund, weil wir Gesichter erkennen. Ich dachte, weil es eine gute Uhrzeit ist, zehn nach zehn. Es ist eine gute Uhrzeit, sagt man gerne. Aber guck mal, alle Uhrzeiten, bei Werbungen sind es immer zehn nach zehn, Uhrenwerbungen immer zehn nach zehn, weil es den offenen, lachenden Mund widerspiegelt und wir das sofort konzentrieren, weil wir überall Gesichter erkennen. Das ist unsere große Magic, wir erkennen überall Gesichter, deswegen erkennt man den Wolken und überall über Gesichter oder auch Bäumen, weil darauf ist unser Gehirn halt aus. Gefahren erkennen, Menschen erkennen. Und so ist bei mir, glaube ich, auch immer Namen, weil unterbewusst erkennt man Fun da drin, F-U-N, klingt zumindest so, und deswegen verspürt der Name Freude. Frage, welche Uhrzeit zeigt eine Uhr an, wenn sie hergestellt wird?
Was ist die erste Uhrzeit, die sie anzeigt?
Ist es immer 12.12 oder ist es, muss man die Zeiger so einsetzen? Ich würde mir echt wirklich so ein tiefes viereinhalb Minuten Gespräch mit einem Uhrmacher gerne haben. So ein Partygespräch, so tiefe viereinhalb Minuten und dann, oh, ich muss weg. Ich muss nochmal zu den Atmosflips rüber. Das hätte ich gerne. Ich hätte gern einen Podcast, wo man mit Experten spricht, aber weil das Problem, was die da im Podcast haben, das geht zu lang. Und irgendwann nervt's. Und Partygespräche, wie du schon sagst, du hast irgendwann die Möglichkeit zu gehen. Man hat sich mit Jacke übergezogen, ich war eh auf dem Sprung, ich gehe kurz raus. Ich muss kurz aufs Klo. Ah, da hinten, die Nina ist ja auch da. Man geht weg. Und das machen diese Podcasts nicht. Deswegen hätte ich gerne so eine Falltür, wo dann die Experten weg machen. Man kann auf den Knopf drücken und der Experte vor allem fällt in den Abyss. Und dann kommt der Nächste rein. Aber kommt der direkt von oben dann wie so ein Partner aus. Von oben, vom anderen Podcast kommt dann der andere, den die Beispiel. Vom Sexpodcast, im Podcast Limbo. Und dann schon wieder Oli P einfach. Aber tatsächlich fände ich es schön, wenn dann der nächste käme direkt. Dann kann man dem direkt herausfinden, was macht der, und wenn er langweilig wird, immer weg. Und am Ende gewinnt derjenige, kriegt dann von Spotify 100.000 Euro, der am längsten da war. Weil er den spannendsten Beruf hat. Und dann hast du so einen sehr nervösen Eulenforscher, der sagt, ja Eulen, die sind nachtaktiv und die Hand über den Buzzer.
Und du hast schon so einen fiesen Gesichtsausdruck, geht dir schon die Hand.
Also es gibt die Schneeule und es gibt verschiedene Jagd, die haben ganz scharfe Klauen.
Und im Mond, wenn der Mond scheint, dann die können die... Ah! Eulen werden nie, also unter meiner Herrschaft wird die Eule nie zum Worst Bird gewählt. Oh, da hast du deine Whitelist. Niemals. Da hebst du deine schützende Hand über die Eulen.
Graureiher und Eulen nicht unter meiner Regie.
Ja, keine Eulen.
Ich mag Eulen sehr gern.
Was fasziniert dich an Eulen?
Dass man sie so selten sieht?
Hat Hedwig einen grossen Einblick hinterlassen?
Nee, Hedwig war mir immer egal.
Ich fand nur, ich find's cool, dass sie sich drehen können.
Ich find's, das find ich absurd und schön und eine ganz tolle Idee von der Natur. Würdest du es auch gerne können? Äh, ja. So einfach so im Straßenverkehr? Einfach mal komplett umdrehen. Also im Supermarkt, wenn hinterher jemand hustet und du uuuup. Wie lange ist das denn entfernt eigentlich noch, dass man so ... Nee, ein paar Jährchen noch. Ja, weil ohne Scheiss, es macht halt keinen Sinn und so, aber viele andere Sachen, die man sich auch einoprieren ... Also wann werden denn ... weil Schönheits-OPs wurden sehr früh perfektioniert. Vielleicht auch nicht, weil man sieht Schönheits-OPs noch, also vielleicht ist da auch noch Optimierungsbedarf. Sieht man sie? Ja, weiß man auch nicht. Die guten nicht, sagt man dann, die schlechten schon, egal. Jedenfalls sieht man, wurde da schon sehr viel Forschung betrieben,
aber bei diesen Gimmick-OPs,
diese, ne, ich hätte nur gern
das Halsgelenk eines
Uhus. Das ist ja
nicht, keine Hexenwerk, man weiß ja, wie es
funktioniert, warum die den ganzen Kopf
drehen können. Wie viele Rotationen möchten Sie?
19. 19 Mal
drehen, dann geht es nicht weiter. Ja, und dann ist wie so ein Gummi zu, so ganz schnell wieder zurück. Ja, das hätte ich gern. Ja, dann müssten wir halt ihre komplette Wirbelsäule entfernen und halt komplett durch ein Eulenskelett ersetzen. Wäre für mich okay, wie lange kann ich nicht arbeiten? Was arbeiten Sie denn? Ich bin Akrobat. Ja, das geht. Das geht gar nicht. Also die, also die Kasse übernimmt das überhaupt kein Problem. Ah, okay, ich dachte, das dauert dann irgendwie nicht einen Monat an Graus oder so. Sie haben dann halt auch einen Teil Eulendena in ihrem Körper. Ja, klar. Das finde ich schön. Kann ich dann auch so fliegen? Naja, das ist halt subtiler so ein bisschen. Also Sie werden vielleicht merken, dass Sie vielleicht nachtaktiver sind, dass Sie vielleicht nachts Heisshunger verspüren oder den Mond fasziniert finden. Also das ist jetzt nicht so was, wo man jetzt sagt, viele kommen hier rein und sagen, habe ich dann Superkräfte, bin ich dann Eulenmann, ich sag nein. Oh man. Nee, ist es nicht. Kann ich die ganzen? Nee, wie gesagt, es hat nichts mit Superkräften zu tun, gar nichts. Gerne, weg damit. Es ist eher subtil, es ist eher eine charakterliche Änderung. Viele Leute gehen hier leider enttäuscht raus, sie denken, sie sind jetzt Giraffenmann oder Schleimmann oder was auch immer. Es ist oft nur eine sehr charakterlich subtile Änderung. Also Slothman wurde einfach langsamer im Kopf ein bisschen. Leicht, leicht einfach. Mit dem kann ich gar nicht mehr reden. Naja, was heißt, der hat halt so um 15 Uhr sagt er, ich lege mich nochmal hin. Und schläft dann durch bis um acht. Und dann sagt er, ich lege mich nochmal, hab ich verpasst, nicht, so kann ich mir nochmal hinlegen. Genau, es ist ein schleichender Prozess. Im Bewassenden des Wortes, ist bei ihm mittlerweile ein schleichender Prozess. Es ist wie gesagt ein subtiler Effekt, also es ist immer schwer, die Leute fragen mich immer, was genau passiert da. Sie reden bei uns nicht gern. Haben Sie Ziegen-DNA in sich drin oder was? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich bin professioneller Schönheitschirurgen. Weil so viel reden und die ganze Zeit mitteilungsbedürftig sind. Aber wie oft kommen die Leute zum Schönheitschirurgen und sagen, ich hätte gerne Flü Flügel. Ich wollte einfach mal fragen, weil irgendwann geht's. How do I start the process? Weil es geht doch. Wo schreibe ich denn hin? Ja, vor allem ich denke mir, irgendwann macht eine Scherz-Klinik auf, die sagt, wir können jetzt Flügel machen und die sitzen dann rum, voller Erwartungen, haben dann die Tonne Feder bestellt und so und niemand kommt und will Flügel. Und die denken, die warten und alles ist bereit und alle freuen sich und diese Rezeptionsbonbonschale ist randvoll gefüllt mit so Nimm zwei mit dem Fruchtkern und alles ist bereit, aber es kommt niemand und die sind alle traurig, weil niemand weiß, dass man Flügel will. Und dann denken sich, dann kommt endlich mal einer rein und sagt Flügel und alle, ja, und yes, yes, du musst es, alle haben gesagt, geh nicht, alle haben gesagt, es geht nicht, alle haben gesagt, du bist ein Idiot, aber ich habe gesagt, nicht, probier es mal und jetzt bin ich hier. Und dann, zwei Minuten später, hob er gern Himmel und flog in den Sonnenuntergang. Ging lächerlich schnell. Aber das wäre aber interessant. So eine Broschüre, so nicht zu hoch fliegen, nicht zu nah an der Sonne fliegen. Icarus. Ja.
Aber ist es tatsächlich, gibt es eine so eine Wissenschaft, die viel weiter ist, als man gerade denkt? Weil wir gerade andere Probleme haben, weil die ganzen Wissenschaftsmagazine darüber nicht schreiben, weil man gerade lieber über, wie befreit man den Ozean von Plastik schreibt, als übrigens, wir können theoretisch jetzt fliegen. Vor allem Journalisten, glaube ich, tun sich schwer, ich habe ja selber
lange Journalismus studiert,
tun sich schwer damit zuzugeben, dass sie was
verpasst haben. Weil, angenommen,
jetzt ist die große Revolution in
der, was heiss ich,
Kamouflagetechnik.
Und dann sagt man, okay, wir
haben uns in der Woche dafür entschieden,
halt irgendwie so eine Ziege, die hat fünf Beine. Haben uns halt dafür entschieden. Und eine Woche später kannst du ja nicht sagen, übrigens, letzte Woche, man muss jetzt nicht mehr so einen dummen Schnurrbart tragen, sondern es gibt jetzt so einen Stift, mit dem malst du dir ins Gesicht und dann wächst da direkt Haare, so dann kannst du dir direkt einen echten Bart aufmalen, so. Aber ist der Journalist so eitel, zu sagen, das war letzte Woche, Das heißt, es geht einfach unter für immer. Das meinst du, oder hat er nicht Angst, noch länger zu warten, weil dann der Backlash ja im Zweifelsfall noch grösser wäre? Nee, das kannst du immer wegschreiben. Es gibt immer eine aktuelle Krise. Du kannst immer über die aktuelle Krise schreiben, du kannst grosse Themen immer unter den Teppich hauen, weil du immer sagst, ja, ach, jetzt ist hier so ein Polarbär weg in so eine Schroere reingeschwommen und steckt da drin. Jetzt ist ein Livecam und ein Hubschrauber und was heißt immer. So, da kannst du immer darüber schreiben und niemand sagt, Moment mal, wo ist der Haarstift? Was ist mit dem Haarstift? Ich sehe den im Supermarkt, ich kann mir echte Barthaare aufmalen. Wo ist der Artikel? Ja, das stimmt wirklich. Oder? So läuft das doch in den deutschen Redaktionsräumen. Das stimmt schon. Man bietet sich Dinge zurecht, man hat Dinge vergessen, man ist so eitel, man ist ja auch nur ein Mensch. Aber ich habe nämlich zum Thema Vermummungstechnik, nämlich ich schaue immer so gerne von Wild oder so, diese Experten, die so Sachen aus ihrem Feld erzählen, so Forensik und sowas. Und da war dann auch eine CIA, ja wer heißt, halt so, die sich verkleiden, halt verstecken, ich versuche ein Wort, es wird nicht albern klingen. Agentin, CSI, ja, aber die halt dafür ist, dass die Leute sich halt den falschen Bart aufkleben, so das ist ihr Job. So, halt so Kamouflage-Make-up-Technik. Anscheinend gibt es das wirklich. Und ich bin immer skeptisch, wenn ich einen CIA-Agenten sehe, der mir die Tricks erklärt, weil ich denke mir, die besten Tricks sagt er natürlich nicht. Der sagt halt so die Anfänger-Tricks. Das ist wie der Zauberer mit der Maske. Ja, weil als ob da jetzt der KGB sitzen würde mit so einem Notizblock und sagt, ja, ja, weiter, weiter, weiter, wir haben hier zehn Leute im Gefängnis,
wo wir nicht wissen, ob der Bart echt ist oder nicht.
Wie finde ich es aus? Ah, okay, am Preisschild.
Erzähl mal. Und die hat dann auch erzählt, so ja, wie man sich anders anzieht und so und dass man, wenn man einen anderen Menschen spielt, dann muss man auch. Wie sieht man sich anders an?
Ja, du musst halt gucken, dass du Lagen hast.
Und Selbstbewusst auch tragen, also Selbstbewusst, weil man strahlt ja auch aus, wenn man sich gerade, ich fühle mich gerade verkleidet,
Das ist ein ganz Torki--talkie aus. Verkabelung unterm Shirt. Ja, und nicht immer fragen, was riecht denn hier nach Bartkleber? Nein, das ist dein Bart. Das ist ein ganz dummer Anfängerfehler. Und deswegen, und dann hat die auch so die Sachen erzählt und ich dachte immer so, das ist doch nicht alles da muss doch mehr sein, das ist doch
da hinkt ja Menschenleben davon ab
und ich denke mir auch immer so bei so Prankshows
wenn die sich dann so verkleiden wie ein alter Mann
und wie Gordon Ramsay verkleidet sich als alter Mann
und ist dann in der Küche bei einem Kochkurs
und dann haha fällt auf, dass es Gordon Ramsay ist
der schon besser kochen kann als der Kochlehrer
und er sieht halt aus wie ein Typ mit Plastiklappen im Gesicht. Das kann doch nicht niemandem aufheilen. Bei Antercover-Boss gibt es das ja auch immer. Ja, die sehen so albern aus. Ja, und das ist einfach immer, weil die kennen ja ihre Chefs auch oft nicht. Da denke ich mir auch oft, das ist ja auch albern. Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie bei Fischer-Dübel arbeitest, weißt du auch nicht, wie der Erbe von Fischer-Dübel oder mittlerweile ein Externer oder so ist, wie der aussieht der Chef unbedingt, weißt du ja nicht, das ist ein Riesenunternehmen teilweise, da kommt ja so eigentlich immer weirde, zu alte Praktikanten an, die immer mit so einem offensichtlichen Makel im Gesicht haben, eine Narbe oder irgendwie eine Augenklappe. Langer Trenchcoat, drei Meter gross, ah und sie soll ich jetzt einleeren oder wie? Hallo!
Und beide Stimmen von den beiden Chefs sagen, ja! Ja, nee, es, aber da denke ich mir immer, wie kann man das nicht erkennen, und das muss ja, da muss Fortschritte geben in der Maskentechnik. Deswegen bin ich da skeptisch, deswegen glaube ich, das ist ein Feld, wo es schon grosse Durchbrüche gab, von denen wir nichts erfahren haben. Ich liebe Experten, ich liebe auch diese Videos, und neulich habe ich auch ein Video gesehen von einem Anwalt, der Better Call Saul geht übrigens weiter. Er ist immer noch da und immer noch toll. Zu lang mittlerweile. Könnt ihr weitergucken? Nee, ich mag das Tempo, ich mag es berühmt, entschleunigt, entschleunigt. Wobei mittlerweile in der Zeit wünscht man sich wieder ein bisschen Beschleunigung vielleicht, aber naja, wenn wir immer noch Entschleunigung gesucht, gerne Better Callol gucken. Da sucht ein Anwalt, schaut die erste Pilotfolge und äh... Ah, Ligel-Igel? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ich liebe Ligel-Igel. Ist das dieser wahnsinnig gut aussehende, selbstbewusste Anwalt? Ja. Der, wie man sich einen Anwalt vorstellt einfach. Oh mein, aber einen amerikanischen Anwalt auch, der eine Jury überzeugen muss. Perfekt angezogen, sieht perfekt aus, kann perfekt sprechen, ist lustig, smart. Ich will mit ihm befreundet sein. Der ist super. Ich will ihn heiraten eigentlich. Ich liebe Ligeligel. Ligeligel? Ja. Das ist was ein bisschen unkugelig. Man könnte es ja eins zu eins auf Deutsch machen, aber halt als Igel. Wäre halt nicht so cool. Aber dann kann der Solmecke, macht den Ligeligel und hat so ein schwarzes Näschen auf. Wir parodieren Sendungen, die keiner kennt.
Ja, genau.
Und spannen den armen Solmecke ein,
der überhaupt nicht weiß, was los ist.
Hallo, sind Sie noch da?
Herr Solmecke!
Nein, wir parodieren, die keiner kennt.
Und die auf so einer grossen Liste schreiben,
Worst-Bread-Production streichen sie durch.
Nie wieder, rote Liste. Und den mag ich sehr gern und der hat normalerweise, also ich liebe Experten, aber normalerweise sagen einem diese Videos, ah okay, ich liebe die Idee des Berufs. Ja. Ich finde die Idee toll, Agent zu sein. Ich finde die Idee toll, keine Ahnung, Mediziner zu sein sein dann gucken die dann die filme und eigentlich sagen
sie mir okay alles was ich daran toll finde ist fiktionalisiert überzeichnet das nicht
praktisch gut finde sobald es ins detail geht nach nicht meins das haben wir auch immer auch
besprochen weswegen wir auch immer glauben dass wir schreiben gerne oder auch in einem
triebisch schreiben oder was auch immer weil wir nur die ideen mögen und so in den ideen verlieren
aber wenig dann die substanz erlernen wollen weil weil die ja auch dann viel Spaß zerstört wieder.
Und lustigerweise war es aber da genau umgekehrt. Er hat bei allen Sachen, die ich geil finde, gesagt, ja genau das passiert auch in amerikanischen Courtrooms und so. Und ich dachte mir jedes Mal, was? Erstens hochgradig unseriös, das Legal System in Amerika ist offensichtlich renovierungsbedürftig, aber auch wie geil, weil ich meine, natürlich muss er dann so einen Affentanz aufführen und er kann einfach irgendwann am Ende, weil das war dann die erste Folge beginnt, wie Saul Goodman so eine meekule Rede hält für drei Jungs, die falsch die Bullshit gemacht haben und es wird auch nicht klar, was sie gemacht haben und er sagt so, ja, wurde jemand verletzt? Nein, es wurde niemand verletzt. Ich habe damals, in meiner Jugend habe ich auch so viel Quatsch gemacht und ich meine, das passiert halt, es ist auch alles okay, es sind drei Jungs mit einem Fehltritt, sind Goofballs, alles gut, niemand ist zu Schaden gekommen, also haben sie schon mal Fehler gemacht? Ja, und dann hat er er die ganze Zeit diese Redeuntersuchung gesagt, ja, genau so bin ich auch.
Emotionalität aufbauen, zu den, halt eine Beziehung von der Jury zu den Leuten aufbauen, immer relatable sein, emotional sein, cool sprechen, am besten auch so Dreierlisten machen und so. Also den ganzen, weil er sagt, es kann ja Ewigkeiten dauern, monatelang das runterbrechen auf drei Punkte und die einem helfen.
Und so und dann kam dann der andere Anwalt, der Staatsanwalt dann auf die Bühne, sag ich mal, hat dann einfach einen Fernseher reingeschoben und man sieht, wie die drei Jungs Toten vergewaltigen und dann musste er auch sehr lachen und hat gesagt, ja, aber genau so kann das aufholen sich. Was, das geht ja nicht. Naja. Manchmal, evidence just speaks for itself. Und dann schiebt man das halt nochmal den Bildschirm rein. Und so, wo ich auch dachte, ja geil, also das würde ich ja lieber sehen. Ich finde das aber auch immer cool, wenn bei dem so durchschimmert, dass das ein Scheissystem ist einfach. Und der das so erklärt, aber immer so mitschwingt,, ja, das ergibt keinen Sinn und dann muss man das und das machen und das dauert viel zu lange, dann ist eigentlich der Fall schon wieder vergessen. Aber so ist es halt und es ist einfach so, als würde er erklären, warum das, wofür er lebt und wofür er arbeitet, einfach komplett an Nonsens ist. So, es ergibt einfach keinen Sinn. Es ist ein bisschen so, als hätte man das, als hätte man sich, man sieht ja immer, man sieht etwas Spannendes und dann, wie kann man es auch spannender machen, zu einer Show machen zum Beispiel, das ist ja normalerweise der deutsche Weg. Wie können wir jetzt Gericht so spannend machen, dass wir es zu einer Show machen können, war was auch der schöne Lug. In Amerika war es, glaube ich, anders. Da hat man von vornherein gesagt, wie kriegen wir eine Show in unser Legal System. Wie wird unser Legal System am coolsten? Wir haben hinten diese Plätze, habe ich gesehen, da passen immer 100 Leute rein, so ist wie so ein kleines Theater, eh schon. Wie machen wir das Ganze ein bisschen peppiger, cooler? Ah, okay, wir bringen Jury rein und es wird so wie so eine Escape Room Experience und man ist, se seien sie hautnah mit dabei wie, sie können sogar entscheiden die Leute tragen Perücken yes, die Leute tragen Perücken und schwarze geile Anzüge, oh mein Gott yes und der hat so einen Hammer und so, oh mein Gott und so, oh mein Gott, bum bum bum bum, stille es gibt noch einen, der das alles malt der malt das alles ab, für Leute, die nicht kommen können eine Frau, die erst mitschreit. Geile Idee, geile Idee.
Einfach um diese Atmosphäre.
Und die Leute können, sie, selbst sie, können rein und entscheiden, wie es dem Angekleiden am Ende endet.
Yes, geil!
Und das Ganze ist umsonst für sie.
Nein!
Sie müssen es sogar machen.
Sie müssen es sogar ein paar Mal entgegen machen.
Ja, aber, Entschuldigung, das ist doch total ungerecht.
Warum?
Naja, weil die Leute, die normalen Leute sind, die kennen sich mit dem Gesetz nicht aus und die wissen nicht, was sie entscheiden und lassen sich viel zu sehr emotional vereinbaren. Richtig! Und das macht es doch erst richtig spannend. Niemand weiß, welche Richtung es geht. Ciao, ich bin in Kanada. Ciao. Selbst der klarste Mordfall kann noch spannend werden. Ich habe eine Rakete. Warum fliegen sie mit einer Rakete nach Kanada? Man weiss gar nichts über Kanada, so die Geschichte von Kanada. An die Jurysystem? Ich weiss nicht, die amerikanische Geschichte, so die Settler und dann die unterschiedlichen Sachen und dann Bürgerkrieg und so, das weiss man alles. Burgerkrieg, Burger King, aber von Kanada weiss ich nichts, null, ausser dass es flächenmäßig deutlich grösser ist, wo man eigentlich mehr drüber wissen sollte. Aha. Das weiss man nicht. Vielleicht brauchen wir noch einen Kanal Kanada irgendwann. Das sind einfach noch die ganzen 19 Bundesstaaten von Kanada nochmal an der Liede. Wirklich? Ich weiss es nicht. Es driftet entweder in Verschwörungspodcasts ab über UFOs oder in Geografie-Podcasts, wo einfach nur Regionen aufgezählt sind. Es gibt diese beiden Wege. Noch stehen wir an der Gabelung und essen und lunchen. Lunchen an der Gabelung, machen kurz Pause. Lunche, bülsen, kleine Beefy. Und ich habe so eine Karte, die ich so halte, dass man sieht, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo wir sind, weil ich sie immer um 180 Grad drehe. Ich war jetzt zu Ostern ein bisschen unterwegs auf Deutschlands Autobahnen. und liebe ... Du bist gegangen, ne? Autobahnen sind ja leer, du bist Iron Legend mässig gegangen. Ich bin spazieren gegangen und ich liebe Autobahnradstätten, ich liebe es, ich liebe es, ich fahre zu jeder einzelnen Radstätte, zu jedem einzelnen Parkplatz, weil ich finde, es gibt nichts, was näher dran ist in unserer Welt an der Raumstation, wo man hinfährt und niemand wohnt da. Ich mag Orte, wo niemand wohnt. Niemand ist da ständig, sondern das ist halt so Durchlauf. Du meinst wie so ein Raumhafen, wie so eine Kantine. Ja genau, wie Mos Eisling. Ein bisschen weniger Musik, aber so da sind so die schmierigen Leute und das ist alles
so, man isst da nur kurz, niemand fühlt sich mit dem Ort verbunden und dadurch schwebt der so ein bisschen in der Luft.
Und dadurch sieht er einfach reudig aus immer.
Absolut. Und jetzt ist vor allem auch alles zu, alle Autobahnen, Gaststätten sind alle zu, das heisst, es ist so wirklich wie so eine kleine verlassene Geisterstadt mit ganz vielen Parkplätzen, wo niemand ist und alles ist zu und dann gibt es irgendwie so Container, weirde Müllcontainer, wo weirdes Zeug drin ist. Du denkst dir, da ist halt eine Leiche drin. Hundertprozentig ist da irgendwo eine Leiche drin. Wenn ich eine Leiche entsorgen würde, würde ich sie an eine Autobahnradstätte in irgendeinen Container werfen. Ganz klar, dann essen sie die Pferde, manchmal ist es ein Pferd, manchmal ist es ein Schaf, ich habe Hühner gesehen, Gänse, die halt dann irgendwie diese Dinge zurückerobern, total weird und dann hast du da so Häuser, wo du denkst, wer wohnt denn direkt neben der Autobahn, wie komplett gestört müssen die Leute denn sein, vor allem in riesigen Feldern, die müssen da nicht wohnen, die können einfach sagen, bauen wir das Haus direkt neben die Autobahn oder 200 Meter entfernt, ne, schon direkt daneben. Naja, oder wurde die Autobahn da dran gebaut. Na, da kannst du nicht das Haus wegschieben oder was. Oder es gibt doch so Bagger, die so Bäume bewegen können, die dann so reinbaggern und dann die ganzen Wurzeln mit rausnehmen. Ja, das geht wahrscheinlich doch. Gibt es doch sowas auch für Häuser, oder? Ja. Also ich liebe Autobahnraschner. Ja, voll, das ist ein ganz spezieller Ort. Ganz weirde Welt irgendwie. Ich finde es auch spannend. Essen ist immer grauenhaft. Also eigentlich ist aber auch hier die Idee besser, weil man kommt dann hin und ist meistens wieder enttäuscht. Ich fahre immer enttäuscht. Ich bin immer sehr euphorisiert parkig, sehr enttäuscht und vom Leben gezeichnet fahre ich dann wieder da weg. Ja, aber ist ja auch gut. Das ist wie so ein Boost-Streifen, wo du gerne hin willst, aber dann auch schnell wieder weg. So weil du denkst, oh Gott, da will ich nicht sein und fährst dann wieder mit neuer Kraft auf die Autobahn zurück. Ist eigentlich ideal. Ich liebe nichts mehr, als dann zum Beispiel getankt zu haben auf einer Autobahn oder auf einer Raststätte zu sein und dann wieder auf die Autobahn zu fahren. Das ist das beste Gefühl, weil es ist wie so ein Boxenstopp. Genau. Und die anderen fahren Vollgas und Now this is Podracing. Du bist wieder einfach dabei. Ja, und du einfach, das Lenkrad wird nach vorne gedrückt, Schub, volle Kraft. Ja, voller Schuh, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bie aber links ist die Autobahn, das heißt, du fährst schon mal auf, beschleunigst schon mal auf hundertzwanzig, dann geht es los, oh, ich liebe es, ich fahr auch zu schnell. Ich bin doch, muss ich sagen, einer von den Menschen, die beim Tempolimit sich immer drastisch zurückhalten bei der Diskussion, weil ich weiß, dass ich die falsche Meinung habe, aber ich liebe es, schnell zu fahren. Aber du stehst trotzdem in der Menge? Du stehst schweigend in der Menge bei solchen Diskussionen?
Ja, ich bin wie Erich Kästner bei der Bücherverbrennung.
Der hat das miterlebt und so und hat sich unter die Nazis gemischt und hat gesehen, wie seine Bücher ins Feuer geworfen wurden.
Und er stand da auch, hat aber nichts gesagt.
Und so bin ich auch.
Und er auch so, Buh, Kästner, Buh.
Och, Grauener.
Och, Emil und die Detektive, langweilig., boring, wohl eher langweilig und die Detektive. E lame, wer sind sie? Ja, werfen sie frei. Nee, jetzt sehe ich es auch. Jetzt sehe ich es auch, dass sie reinwerfen. Jetzt sehe ich es auch. Er war ja selber immer ein harter Kritiker seiner eigenen Arbeit und deswegen war er da auch. War er da auch. Er war erleichtert. Aber wenn jemand zu dir sagen würde, pass auf Stefan, wir verbrennen alles von dir. Würdest du nicht auch ein bisschen sagen so, ja, Spaß schon. Ich bin da echt bei. Dass die gute Arbeitsgäsche immer noch im Internet zu finden sind. Nee, hau das weg. Ja, wirklich, das wird alles gelöst. Verbrennt die Server. Ja, die große Buchlöschung. Aber so bin ich auch ein bisschen, also ich weiss, dass ich die falsche Meinung habe. Und manchmal sage ich dann auch, ja, Stimmen muss weg, Tempolimit muss her. Das macht ja keinen Sinn, auch ökologische Sicherheitsfähigkeit. Aber tief in mir denken, also nicht tief, nicht immer tief, man muss nur ganz kurz graben. Und dann ist meine Meinung schon sehr offensichtlich. Ich liebe es schnell zu fahren. Ja. Und ich hasse Tempolimits Diskussionen. Und tatsächlich gibt es ja dann immer die Autofahrer, die von hinten dann rankommen und ganz schnell fahren und nicht wegblicken. Und ich denke mir immer, weil der erste Reaktion ist, was für ein Arschloch, was für ein Assi. Ich denke mir aber, lass ihm das. So, das ist alles, was er in seinem erbärmlichen Leben hat. Schnell zu fahren in seinem Auto. Der hat sonst keine Freude im Leben. Der flieht literally vor seinen Problemen, so schnell er kann. Lass ihm das, mein Gott. Lass mir das, ich bin der der Linksflüge. Wir kennen alle Argumente, ist klar, aber ich denke mir, mein Gott, komm, gib ihm das. Ich finde, manche muss man... Man kann es ihm vorwerfen, ja. Manche muss man bei Auslöchern auch einfach sagen, wenn die das nicht hätten, hätten sie gar nichts. Wenn sie jetzt nicht meckern könnten, hätten sie nichts. Ist okay. Komm, mecker. Ist okay. Man sollte sich lieber freuen, dass man das selber nicht braucht. Dass man selber nicht, dass man ein schönes Leben hat, auch ohne zu rasen auf der Autobahn. Ich verstehe so viele Argumente auch immer. Also Gefahr für andere, dass es mehr die Umwelt schädigt. Du wichst es halt auf mit Bock auf der anderen Seite. Ich wichst es auf mit fun,
Bock und so.
Naja.
Was ich nicht verstehe, ist immer,
da kommt immer ein Argument, was ich immer,
ein Argument, was ich wegwetzen
kann, was nämlich dann ist,
man ist ja gar nicht schneller am Ziel.
Ich bin deutlich schneller am Ziel
dann immer, wenn ich rase. Naja, also ich bin immer, ich habe es ein paar Mal gemessen, weil ich dieses Argument immer so seltsam fand, paradox fand. Es ist, ich bin deutlich schneller am Ziel. Natürlich. Das ist auch nicht die Mega-Erkenntnis, dass wenn man schneller fährt, man ... Eben. Schnell am Ziel ist es, dass nicht die Definition von schnell. Ja, das dachte ich nämlich auch, aber dann kommen immer die Leute, die sagen, ja man ist ja nachweislich nicht schneller, weil du dann, die Leute, die schneller fahren, stehen länger in Ampeln oder was ist die Ohne jetzt zu lang in diesem Motorsport der Folge abzudriften, wir lieben einfach Autofahren. Letztens hatte ich, und das ist echt ein Genuss, hatte ich das perfekte Ampelanfahren, was meine ich? Und zwar ist es ja oft so, es gibt das Schlecht. Niemand hat gefragt. Das Schlechtste, stell dir vor, zehn Autos stehen vor einer roten Ampel in der Schlange. Der schlechteste Fall ist, die Ampel wird grün, der erste fährt los, der zweite merkt erst daran, dass der erste fährt, dass es grün geworden ist, fährt dann erst los. Der dritte merkt erst, wenn sich das zweite Auto bewegt, oh, so, verstehst du, was ich meine? Summiert sich langsam. Summiert sich. Und die andere Spur ist schon viel weiter, denkt man. Genau, und am Ende fahren drei Autos durch. Beste Fall ist, alle zehn Autos sehen, es wird grün, fahren alle exakt gleichzeitig an und fahren gleichzeitig als Kolonne los. Du sagst utopisch, ich sag habe ich erlebt, habe ich genau so erlebt, dass alle losfahren gleichzeitig, weil es ist ja fast ein blindes Vertrauen, weil du musst ja fahren, bevor sich das Auto vor dir bewegt. Da muss viel zusammenkommen. Da muss mega viel zusammenkommen und ich war wirklich, das war wirklich so ein Ballettmoment, wo ich dachte so, es greift alles in sich. Ich findeonnen auch schön. In Filmen, Sicario. Viva Colonia, sagst du? Viva Colonia. Aber Sicario ist zum Beispiel ein sehr schöner Film, den ich mir vor allem gerne angucke, weil diese Kolonnenfahrten, finde ich, die befriedigen mich aufs Tiefste. Das finde ich so schön, aber das ist ein tolles Gefühl. Denke ich mir nämlich auch, alle Menschen könnten schneller sein, alle ein bisschen schneller, zack, zack werden. Ja, das ist so, zehn Menschen haben unabhängig voneinander die richtige Entscheidung getroffen und aneinander geglaubt. Und gesagt, ich glaube, dass mein Mitmensch auch klug ist. Glaubst du, das liegt doch gerade so ein bisschen an der Stimmung, die gerade herrscht, sozusagen gemeinsam haben wir was in der Hand, wir alle können was bewegen, dass es daher kam vielleicht, dass alle gesagt haben, wenn ich allen vertraue, dann kann dann jetzt. Komm, wir fahren jetzt alle gemeinsam los und fahren gemeinsam unser Ziel. Kann sein, aber es war einfach. Dann seid ihr dann in der Kolonne zusammen nach Afghanistan gefahren? Wir sind komplett durchgefahren, komplett durch zum McDrive, zum Kentucky Drive. Und alle haben gleichzeitig bestellt. Ja, alle dasselbe. Und jetzt seid ihr immer noch in so einer weirden Choreo-Gruppe. Wenn man so Stangen an den Armen hat, und man so zwei Puppen vor sich und hinter sich hat. Genau so. Aber ich war wirklich so euphorisiert. Ich dachte mir, wow. Hast du laut gejubelt? Ich habe wirklich laut gejubelt. Ich habe gerufen und ich dachte mir, das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Wie diese Geräusche, die man manchmal in so Montagen hat dann noch. Yeah! Woohoo! Ja, das ist eine gute Zeit. Wo sich das zum Glück schneiden die genau in dem Moment in die Montage rein, wo der gerade wuuu macht, wenn er irgendwie mit einem offenen Verdeck das Auto, er steht auf dem Rücksitz, macht die Arme auf und macht wuuu und dann macht er immer wieder wuu die die ganze Phase. Ich will wirklich noch einmal in meinem Leben einen Film machen, eine Serie machen, wo es eine Montage gibt, in der nichts funktioniert. Das habe ich noch nie so richtig gesehen, weil auch ich neulich wieder Knöpfe ins Ohr, schön Musik an, der Song, den ich gut finde, genau auf dem richtigen Moment die Tür aufgemacht, Sonne strahlt mir ins Gesicht, Sonnenbrille auf und dann kurz umgucken und denken, here we go. Dann Song beginnt richtig, ich gehe raus, für den Internet fällt die Tür ins Schloss, ich habe meinen Schlüssel vergessen und dann musste ich so zur Tür springen, damit die Tür nicht ins Schloss fällt, weil ich mich ausgesperrt hätte fast und mache dann so einen lächerlichen Sprung und so schwitze, weil ich diesen Schockmoment nicht verknüpfe. Das sieht man dann nicht. Oh, komm, Hörer fallen raus. Komm, hörer fallen raus, in den Gulli rein, oh mein Gott. Dröhnt von unten, die Erde bebt vom Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack, und die ganze Straße und du so sorry, sorry, leiser. Bitte ein bisschen leiser. Ich habe noch keine Küche, aber ich habe einen Grill. Yes. Schön, und hier gibt es einen ganz tollen Fischladen in der Nähe, wo man frischen Fisch kaufen kann. Hat die Grill-Saison angefangen für dich? Die hat für mich angefangen, ich habe sie eingeläutet mit ganz tollem Fisch auf dem Grill, das macht ganz viel Spaß. Was sind auch so Fischklemmen, wo die noch eingesperrt werden müssen, bevor sie sterben? Ja, genau, ich habe Fischklemmen. Leider Gottes sind die Enten aus Plastik gewesen, weshalb die geschmolzen sind dann während des ja doch sehr heissen Grillprozesses, wäre das gesagt, und deswegen sind die am Rand zerlaufen. Auf eine Art auch spannend. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe, die Butter ist halt reingelaufen in den Grill, weshalb eine Stichflamme entstanden ist mehrere Male und die Nachbarskinder waren doch sehr, ja, eine Mischung aus ehrfürchtig interessiert am Fenster gestanden, aber auch wahnsinnig ängstlich und haben dann ihre Eltern gerufen, weil es draußen brennen würde. Och, und wieder Verachtung bei mir drauf, auch auf Stirn, Verachtung, Verachtung. Und du, ihr wollt mal ein Feuer sehen? Und dann hast du den Kanister Spiritus noch reingepackt. Spiritus einfach, ihr wollt Feuer sehen? Ja, ja. Ich stelle mir dich wirklich komplett am Rande des Warnens vor, wie du komplett nackt, nur mit so einer Kiste Chef-Schürze dastehst, irgendwie einer Hand Bierdose, anderer Hand Spiritusflasche, abwechselnd trinkst, abwechselnd reinsprinzt und einfach Fisch grillen. Man tut sich auch auf und zu immer mit Spiritus und Bier in der Hand, klar, weil man hat ja auch schon drei Intus, von daher weiss man auch nicht mehr genau. Einen für dich, einen für mich. So stelle ich mir dich irgendwie vor, mit so einer Zange und dann klapperst du immer so. Ja, klapper, klapper ich immer.
Man wird ja beim Grillen auch zu einem toxischen, da kommt dann meine toxische Masculinity auch hoch, merke ich dann. Sonst habe ich nicht viel, je mehr Krebserregelstoffe du einatmest. Je mehr Masculine an mir, aber das ist dann tatsächlich, da ballert es dann raus. Ja. Auch als ich diesen Grill aufgebaut habe. und das ist ein Gasgrill und deswegen habe ich den aufgebaut und wirklich, also man sollte, ich sollte keinen Gasgrill aufbauen dürfen, allein schon. Weil am Ende dieser Kette steht ja dann, also es ist viel Schrauben und viel nochmal nachgucken und viel, habe ich das jetzt richtig rum eingebaut? Aber am Ende dieser Problemkette ist ja ein Gasgrill, der mit Gas heizt. Holy shit, da ist eine Gasflasche drin. Ich habe zu viel Respekt vor Gas. Habe ich zu viel Respekt davor. Es waren also verschiedene Stunden lang aufbauen und dann zwei Stunden lang, habe ich dann irgendwo gesehen, soll man machen, so ein Blumenspritzgerät, so ein Spritzer, so eine Flasserspritzflasche. Da soll man Seife reinmachen und Wasser, da hat man so eine Seifenflüssigkeit und dann soll man halt die Enden, wo es rausgasen könnte, soll man anspritzen und gucken, ob sich da Bläschen bilden. Und das habe ich bestimmt, also aufbauen war eine Stunde und dann habe ich zwei Stunden lang habe ich das gemacht, diesen Grill angespritzt und ich dachte, was macht er denn jetzt? Aber ich habe ewig dann diesen Grill angespritzt, um zu gucken, wo dann diese Bläschen jetzt entstehen könnten und so. Und das ist sicher, das ist sicher. Ich traue der Sache trotzdem noch nicht. Ich würde dem nie trauen, würde dem wirklich nie trauen. Also du kommst mich jetzt nicht besuchen. Null, auf der keine Chance. Wir machen keinen schönen Bierabend bei mir. Was ich gut fände, weil zum Beispiel bei so Lego-Sets, wenn du so einen Lego-Kran kaufst, gibt es ja immer ein B-Modell, was du aus den gleichen Teilen auch noch bauen kannst. Dann kannst du Kran bauen, aber auch einen Hubschrauber. So was, finde ich, sollte es auch bei so einem Grill geben. A-Modell Grill, B-Modell irgendwie so ein Feuerspruch oder Dinosaurier oder irgendwie sowas. Wo du einfach so ein Locker ist, wenn du sagst, vor allem dann, wenn du den Grill nicht mehr brauchst, dann kannst du sagen, nee, dann lass uns einfach ins B-Modell bauen. Und dann kannst du noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so einen romantischen Flammenwerfer oder sowas haben, der dann irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, in so einer Herzform dann so eine Stichflamme hat. Ja, aber schon so acht Meter hoch. Deko. Ja, das ist der schönste Geräusch der Welt. Ich glaube nicht, wie wahnsinnig laut Flammenwerfer sind. Ich wohne ja neben einer Baustelle, wie mittlerweile jeder weiß, weil es mich nervt und ich mich überall beschwere, dass es so fucking laut ist.
Du beschwerst dich überall?
Es sind vor allem die Dinge... Du beschwerst dich.
Ja, ich habe wirklich Vorstellungen davon, dass ich wirklich sieben Uhr morgens im Bett liege und Presslufthammer an und ich denke mir, ich gehe da jetzt rüber und schneide dem das Kabel ab oder schneide dem was auch immer, wie so ein Ding funktioniert, so ein Stromabnehmer oben in der Luft, wie so ein, wie so ein, ach komm, wie so ein, wie so ein, wie heissen die? Ne, da muss es alleine durch. Die Boxautos, wo man sich boxen mit den Autos. Das ist der Moment, wo die Mentorfigur am Rand steht und guckt, wie du zum ersten Mal auf die Feinde triffst. Use the force. Use the force. Ja, but I got no force. I got no force. Autoscooter. Wie so ein Autoscooter, das so oben so den Strom abnimmt. Das ist immer das Problem bei Baustellen, dass sie ja erstmal das Dach bauen müssen. Mit allen elektronischen Geräten, mit diesem Ding da oben. Wahnsinn, oder? Was ein tolles System. Unfassbar, ne? Ich habe mir oft als Kind gedacht, warum sind nicht alle Autobahnen so? Ja, aber in Holland gibt es das auch mittlerweile schon. Ja, Autosgutadliche. Wo die so Induktionsschleifen gedöhnt haben unter dem Schönen. Und du hast dann so einen Pinsel am Boden. Wie Karrierabahn. Der Lkw-Fahrer sitzt vorne und die Haare stehen ihm zu bergen. Er ist komplett stromvoll gepumpt, aber sagt Ui, für die Umwelt. Zu Berge stehen sagt man nur bei Harem, oder? Warum ist das so klar vernetzt? Vor allem irgendjemand da draußen lernt Deutsch und hat eine Karteikarte, auf der steht zu Berge stehen und fragt sich.
Wofür lerne ich das?
Soll ich das lernen? Oder ich komme oft an so Vokabeln, wo ich mir denke, komm, scheiß drauf.
Ja, scheiß mal jetzt drauf.
Das nimmst du wirklich nie. Aber irgendjemand hat gelernt zu Berge stehen in seinem Deutschkurs und hat es nie verwendet und denkt sich einfach verschwendete Zeit und freut sich jetzt. Ja. Freut sich jetzt gerade, weil er oder sie sagt, yes, zu Berge. Ich verstehe es. Haare stehen zu Berge. Zu Berge, zur Berg, zu Berge. Zu Berge. Wie? Es ist auch vor allem, Elektrizität ist das größte Wunder der Menschheit vielleicht, aber das erste, was man macht, ist, wenn man einen Luftballon hat, ist sich die Haare zuhöh stehen lassen, dann den Luftballon an die Decke kleben und das war's. Das ist das Wunder der Elektrizität. Elektrizität ist aber auch sowas wie, ich glaube, das ist sowas, was die Menschheit auch ein bisschen polarisiert im Sinne von Wissen darüber.
Ich glaube, du hast zwei Lager auf der Welt, beide sind gleich intelligent, aber beide, die einen wissen komplett, wie Elektrizität funktioniert und die anderen haben einfach akzeptiert, dass sie es nicht wissen müssen. Ich weiss noch, an jedem Kindergeburtstag, wo es Luftballons gab, hahaha, über den Kopf reiben, irgendwo hinkleben. Und ich stelle mir nur die Eltern vor, die dann so nervös danebensitzen. Bitte frag nicht, warum das klebt. Bitte, bitte. Ich weiß, ich kann nicht mal so tun. Ich kann nicht meine Antwort fake. Mir fehlen da selbst für eine Fake-Antwort-Vokabeln. Keine Ahnung. Mama, warum klebt das an der Decke? Oh mein Gott! Weil das statisch aufgeladen ist, Schatz. Was bedeutet statisch aufgeladen? Ja, okay. So, hier ist Mortal Kombat. Mama geht kurz in die Küche. Ja, man hört nur so, wie ein Ramazzotti geöffnet wird. Hektisch. Einfach keine Chance. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe einen ganz tollen YouTube-Kanal entdeckt, der dir auch sehr gut gefallen wird, Sixty Symbols heißt der, und das ist irgendeine Universität, ich glaube in Nottingham oder so, wo irgendeine der Studenten einfach seine Physikprofessoren interviewt und ihnen einfach Fragen stellt und teilweise auch zusammenschneidet, was die auf dieselbe Frage verschiedene Professoren sagen, wie die die Fragen beantworten würden, und ist supergeil und richtig toll. Und da gibt es dann auch tatsächlich ein Video darüber, dass man nicht genau weiß, wie das funktioniert, warum, wenn man zwei Sachen aneinander reibt, warum da halt die Elektronen wechseln. Ach so, das weiss ich nicht. Also warum das eine aufgeladen wird, also warum das eine Plus ist und das andere Minus, man weiss das nicht ganz genau. Und das benutzt jeder so, aber weiss man halt nicht genau. Total spannend. Okay, das heißt, die Mutter in unserem fiktiven Szenario könnte sogar einfach ein PhD haben. Genau, und könnte sagen, man weiss es nicht. In der Physik, aber sie weiss es nicht. Man weiss es nicht genau. Vielleicht weil durch Reibung einfach ganz oft es in Kontakt kommt und dadurch sich diese Bindungskräfte dann vielleicht wieder reisen. Ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, wenn ich mit den Fingern aneinander reibe, genüsslich, da muss doch was passieren. Wird sein, ja. Da muss doch was passieren, rechts, rechts, links. Oh, ich bin fast gestorben an Strom. Ja, ja, die Wohnung, in der ich jetzt wohne, ist ja noch ein bisschen eine Baustelle und da hingen dann einfach lose Kabel von der Decke. Und du dachtest, Autoscooter. Da wurde so eine Trockenbauwand weggemacht und da hingen dann noch so ein Kabel von der Decke. Und du dachtest Autoscooter. Da wurde so eine Trockenbauwand weggemacht und da hing dann noch so ein Kabel von der Decke. Ich dachte, die Schreinerin, die das gemacht hat, die hat das dann vernünftig gesichert oder die Sicherung rausgemacht. Dem solchen Leuten vertraue ich dann einfach auch blind. Die wissen mehr als ich in dem Gebiet. Da habe ich mir einen Schrank gebaut und den daneben gestellt. Da musste ich das ein bisschen wegschieben, dieses locker hängende Kabel und plötzlich höre ich nur ein Funken spritzt, wirklich so ein Stromball entlädt sich, ich kurz daneben und das war Kurzschluss und sofort ist der FI rausgefallen und so und ich war wirklich kurz davor an so einer Steckdose, jetzt nicht zu sterben, aber doch einen krassen Schlag zu bekommen. Aber dein Schrank hat den abbekommen, oder was? Oder wie? Nee, die Wand dann. Die Wand. Ich habe durch den Schrank, den ich da herangeschoben habe, einen Kursschluss ausgelöst an dieser locker hingen Steckdose. Und das war wirklich super gruselig. Und dann ist nachher so ein bisschen Brandspuren an der Wand jetzt zu erkennen. Es ist wirklich gruselig. Und dann habe ich sofort den elektrischen Notdienst von Köln angerufen, weil die mir das dann sichern sollten, weil ich echt Angst hatte dann. Wo ich dann auch so dachte, ich bin wahnsinnig überfordert mit dem Umzug. Und wer kam dann? Kam dann so ein ... Halit kam dann, Megatyp. Wir haben auch Nummern ausgetauscht, wir sind jetzt gute Freunde geworden inzwischen, einfach auch, weil ich mir dann ihn so ein bisschen als Vaterfigur jetzt auch heranziehe. Also kommen wir so jede Woche vorbei. Kommen wir vorbei. Wir können ja pokern, aber du kannst halt auch gucken, ob die Sicherung... Ja, dass er alles sicher ist, okay. Halit war da, der war mega und der hat mir das dann alles gesichert, hat auch einen Haufen Geld gekostet, weil diese Notdienste halt Geld kosten, wahnsinnig viel für Anfahrt und sowas zu berechnen, aber ging leider nicht anders, alle anderen, derzeit habe ich abzulehnt, die konnten alle nicht so schnell kommen, aber das war wirklich gruselig, aber ich kurz dachte, ja, so schnell kann es halt gehen. Da hätte ich auch... Die meisten Unglücke passieren im Haushalt. Ja, ich habe vor allem auch bei mir in Hamburg, habe ich auch bei meinem Bett direkt über der Matratzenhöhe, also direkt da, wo man schläft, ist auch ein relatives Loch in der Wand, wo Kabel rausstehen. Einfach Kabel raus und ich denke halt immer so, ja, ich schlafe da halt. Aber sind da Lüsterklemmen drauf? Weiß ich doch nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich denke mal, es ist eher ein Antennenkabel oder sowas, also nicht so schlimm, aber kann halt auch sein, dass ich eines Tages mich halt hin und her rolle und ein Zentimeter weiter und ein und da BATZ! Ja. Bin ich einfach weg. Aber der beste Tod, der bestmögliche Tod. Wahrscheinlich. Im Schlaf elektrisiert. Träumt man eigentlich noch? Willst du das ein bisschen? Willst du das vielleicht? Hast du deswegen noch nicht dieses Loch gestopft? Angenommen, jemand würde dir sagen, angenommen, dein Todesalter steht jetzt fest. Wann? Wir ziehen fünf Jahre ab, dafür stirbst du im Schlaf, ohne es zu merken, ohne Schmerz. Und der andere Tod? Weiß man nicht. Ich würde fünf Jahre länger leben wollen. Echt? Ja. Aber wir können dealen, Herr Sensenmann, wir können dealen, wenn du jetzt sagst, Sie sagen, Entschuldigung, zwei Jahre ne, fünf. Oder drei Jahre, dann würde ich auch. Naja, ich sag mal so, ich kann Ihnen jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, wie lange Sie leben werden, aber es ist eine Ordnung, also Sie haben noch ein paar, Sie haben noch Jährchen. Ja? Ja, ja, ja. Ich? Ja, ja. Ich rase. Ja, ja, nein, Sie rase.
Ich rase auf Autobahn. Ja, aber
das ist lächerlich. Das reichlich.
Sag ich doch, es ist Mumpitz. Genau.
Sie sind auch gegen Tempolimitz.
Ich weiß, man sagt das nicht und man,
ich bin dann immer still. Danke.
Ja, wenn es dann immer heißt, von wegen, wegen der
Umwelt und so, ich verstehe die Argumente ja,
aber mein Gott, trotzdem.
Aber gut, wer bin ich denn?
Der Tod. Wer bin ich denn, Tipps zu geben, für Sicherheit? Naja, also ich sag mal so, egal, egal, was sie sich vorstellen als ein gutes Alter, sie erreichen das auch mit fünf weniger. Wie gesagt, ich darf Ihnen leider nicht sagen, wie lange es ist, aber Und dann ein guter Tod. Was ist denn mein Tod? Nur mal so ein Hinweis. Na, das darf ich ... Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich darf auch so vieles nicht. Ich komme da wirklich in Teufelsküche, also wortwörtlich. Wortwörtlich in Teufelsküche? Ja, das ist schrecklich. Diese Risottoabende, das ist grauenvoll. Man kommt da nicht weg und man nimmt die Musik an und das ist furchtbar. Man kann sich nicht losreisen. Man kann sich da echt nicht nicht losreißen. Nur mal so um welche Richtigen, es geht eher Unfall oder ist es dann doch Selbstmord? Ähm, nee, das nicht. Also das kann ich ausschliessen. Unfall, ja, na ja, es ist spannend, es ist spannend, es ist, sag ich mal, ich sag mal so, ich kann Ihnen einen Tipp geben, man kann es nicht genau in eine Kategorie anwenden. Das ist aber, nee, aber jetzt habe ich mich, jetzt habe ich eh schon zu viel gesagt. Wissen Sie, von allen Toten, nur von den Menschen auch von Tieren, das habe ich mir schon gefragt. Nee, alle Tiere auch, tatsächlich. Alle Tiere, reden Sie mit denen auch? Tiere und Menschen sind gleichwertig. Ja, aber reden Sie mit denen auch, wie mit mir jetzt? Reden Sie mit denen? Tieren? Ja, oft lohnt es sich oft dann nicht mehr die Anfahrtskosten, dann bei so einem Kaninchen, der zwei Jahre lebt. Wie Sie dem sind gerade gesagt, die sind genau so viel wert wie Menschen. Ja. Verzetteln sich auch ein bisschen. Ja, aber ich sag mal, es gibt auch bei den Tieren, welche die länger leben, wo es angenehmer ist. Da kannst du anfahren, da kannst du ein Wochenende planen, dann kannst du sagen, so eine Galapagos, kannst du sagen, hier pass auf. Erscheinen Sie denen dann als Tierform oder auch als Mensch? Nee, auch als Mensch, tatsächlich. Was? Das muss schon sein. Ich war ja auch mal ein Mensch. Ja? Ja, ja. Wie wird man denn dann Dinsenmann? Ach Gott, das ist jetzt, da will ich jetzt nicht. Nee, aber wie wird man das dann? Weil das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Dann gebe ich hier meine Autobiografie, totgelacht, da steht alles drin. Danke. Bis der Tod euch scheidet, Teil zwei, nicht so gut, aber der Verlag meinte noch, das muss sein. Auch Autobiografie? Es ist ein Ghostwriter mit dem Spiel, egal, völlig irrelevant. Aber auch im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ist es wahrscheinlich ein Ghostwriter, oder? Es war der Geist von Goethe. Also es ist kein schlechter Ghostwriter.
Aber wahrscheinlich trifft er den Ton nicht aus dem ersten Teil.
Ja, dieses Reimen ist schwer. Da musste ich nochmal drüber.
Kennen Sie alle Toten persönlich?
Och Gott, nicht alle, nee.
Aber Goethe war cool?
Ich habe mich mal an Goethe gewendet, ein ganz netter Kerl, aber auch anstrengend, muss man sagen, anstrengend.
Was war denn der coolste, wo man sagt, Einstein, was war denn die beeindruckende Persönlichkeit? Ich sag mal, ja, ich habe halt erstmal die grossen abgeklappert, Napoleon, Hitler, Gandhi, habe ich abgeklappert. Alle cool. Alle tolle Leute, muss man sagen, auch verstehen sich sehr, sehr gut auch tatsächlich nach dem Tod. Gandhi und Hitler? Gandhi und Hitler sind beste Freunde. Wirklich? Die spielen jedes Wochenende Tennis. Spielen Tennis? Jedes Wochenende Tennis und ich will nicht sagen, wer gewinnt, aber es ist nicht der, von dem sie denken, dass er gewinnt. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wer von beiden. Eben. Aber tragen die dann auch so enge Höschen, so enge weisse Shorts? Ja, wie gesagt, modisch tut sich da nicht mehr viel. Das ist dann schon, schon, und Gandhi mit seinem, naja, anderes Thema. Wie gesagt, aber ich sag mal so, Richard der Zweite, das ist ein Juwel, das ich erst nach langem entdeckt habe. Toller, toller Kerl. Was hat er gemacht? Toller Humor. Ja, Vater umgebracht halt so, um selber König zu werden. Heiktes Thema, spricht ja nicht gern drüber. Klassiker. Klassiker, aber er freut sich halt schon über das Theaterstück von ihm. Er sagt, es ist historisch nicht ganz korrekt, was Shakespeare da geschrieben hat. Ja, gut. Viel Diskussion. Wie gesagt, Shakespeare rät nicht mehr mit ihm. Da gab es anscheinend irgendeinen Konflikt, da war ich nicht dabei. Naja, alles gut. Also, wilde Typen, aber wie gesagt. Ne, ja spannend. Also wenn wir mal einen Podcast machen könnten oder sowas,
finde ich super, weil ich liebe es, Experten einzuladen, meine Podcasts. Ja, aber sie sind sehr kritisch auch. Sie sind sehr kritisch. Moment mal, was ist das für ein Knopf? Ne, was? Ne, ich fände es ja schon spannend mit ihnen. Also was ich noch sagen kann, Napoleon ist echt ein toller Typ. Ne! Ne! Nein!
Aber hast du einen Wunsch-Tod? Kannst du formulieren, wie du gerne sterben würdest? Ja, Flugzeugabsturz. Okay. Oder schön noch Con-Air schauen und dann ... Ich will Nachrichtentod sterben. Ja? Ja. Also, ist das eine Nachricht, weil du berühmt bist oder weil der Tod so spektakulär ist? Weil der Tod so spektakulär ist. Ich habe Angst, dass ich nicht wichtig genug bin. Ich hätte, zum Beispiel, auch, naja, ich denke immer ein bisschen in Wikipedia-Artikeln, ich denke mein Leben in Wikipedia-Artikeln, meine Entscheidungen beruhen darauf, klingt das jetzt besser so oder so im Wikipedia-Rien. So dieses, von seiner eigenen Erfindung getötet, ist eine beliete Wikipedialiste. Oh, mega. Ja, so aber auch allein oben dann schon Eyecatcher, geboren in Carmen, gestorben in Buenos Aires, finde ich jetzt auch schon cooler. Ist schon gut, ja. Also allein, dass man da schon so ein Teaser und dann geht das Intro los und dann kommt die Serie. Man will ja erst schon mal ein bisschen so den Leser am Schlawittchen. Ja, 1. Januar 2100, gestorben in Buenos Aires. Genau. So, um 0.01 Uhr. Ja, was ist passiert? Ja genau, was ist da passiert? Wir wissen es nicht. Bis heute unabverklärt. Was war da? Fragezeichen. Genau, gestorben in Fragezeichen. Wir wissen nicht genau wann, aber in Peru. Genau, bestattet in Buenos Aires und Kiel. So zwei Orten bestattet. Okay, das ist interessant. Ja, genau, sowas finde ich, das wurden, es, manche sagen aber auch, er ist in Japan gestorben. Er wurde da nämlich zur gleichen Zeit gesehen. Und Flugtickets belegen auch eigentlich die Reise dahin. Ich will auch, dass da eine True-Crime-Serie drüber entsteht. Und dann so Lazarus-Effekt mässig, dass du dann doch noch lebst, obwohl du schon für tot befunden wurdest. Und dann bist du so staatenlos, weil du existierst offiziell nicht mehr. Dann gibt es ein Von-bis, 1994 bis 2023. Und dann gibt es nochmal einen, und dann nochmal, 2078 wieder aufgetaucht. Aber unter anderem Namen.
Unter anderem Namen und ist nicht gealtert in der Zeit.
Genau. Und niemand weiß, ob er wirklich dieselbe Person ist oder nicht.
Genau. Oder ein Kind.
Das ist ein Mysterium. Wir kriegen kaum noch Mysterien hin als Zuschriften, was nicht schlimm ist.
Was schlimm ist, aber was er auch sagt, die Welt ist aber auch gelöst.
Absolut. Nee, das ist gut. Oder die Leute trauen uns einfach nicht zu, dass wir die Probleme lösen können. Und unsere Anforderungen waren ja auch denkbar klein und eng. Wie kann es sich nicht mehr so ein, wie es sich nicht mehr so ein, wie es sich nicht mehr so ein, um das mal zu sagen. Weil wenn Leute mir wirklich doch schreiben so, vielleicht ist da ein Luftballon geplatzt. Ja, du Depp, ich bin mir schon klar, dass es viele Gründe für den Knall geben kann, aber über Wochen lang,
jede Nacht, niemand weiß
woher. Das ist... Wollen wir mal den
dümmsten Hörer wählen eigentlich?
Worst, worst audience. Ja, genau.
Ja, worst Hörer,
worst Hearst. Worst Hearst.
Das ist
also da habe ich wirklich, ohne euch
zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber da habe ich ein paar Kandidaten.
Da habe ich ein paar E-Mail-Adressen gespeichert. Also was da teilweise für Sachen kommen, aber gut, ist ein anderes Thema. Können auch immer Gags sein, wissen wir nicht. Es gab auch natürlich ganz viele Leute, die uns vorgerechnet haben, wie viel eine Tonne ein Cent Münzen wert ist. Ich glaube ein paar tausend Euro, zwei tausend, dreitausend Euro oder so, nicht viel, aber das wissen wir jetzt auch. Mir gefällt nicht, dass du das Passwort hast zu dem E-Mail-Account, weil ich diese ganzen Antworten, die spannend sind, ich stelle dir eigentlich nur Fragen und sterbe dumm. Und du hast dann irgendwann, in der Nebenzeit sagt es mir noch, wir haben Probleme gelöst, Menschheit. Auf der anderen Seite, hast du gerade gesagt, wir haben noch ein Mysterium bekommen? Wolltest du noch ein Mysterium moderieren? Nein. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Es kam kein Mysterium mehr. Wir wissen nicht mehrien. Es gab aber ein paar Theorien und da wird es jetzt ein bisschen
creepy, sag ich mal.
Nämlich zu dem Thema,
dass jemand geschrieben hat,
weil da hatte ja unsere
Hörerin, die uns geschrieben hat von ihrer Oma,
die geschrieben hat über den Vormieter
ihres Hauses, der
ein böse,
ein böser, gieriger
Goldschmied war. Und jemand hat uns geschrieben, vielleicht heißt böse und gierig auch einfach nur Jude. In dem Kontext. Als Vormieter der Oma und der ist dann irgendwann verschwunden und sein Geld ist weg und dann hat die Oma da gewohnt. Also vielleicht ist das gar kein Mysterium, warum sein Geld nicht da ist, sondern vielleicht, man weiß es nicht. So, das war die Theorie, was diese ganze charmante Geschichte entzaubert. Haben wir es gelöst? Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es gelöst haben, aber ich sage, danke, danke Nazis, dass ihr uns diese schöne, romantische, wohlige Mystery-Story genommen habt. Ja, na ja, jetzt wollen wir der Hörerin ja auch nicht so nahe treten. Überhaupt nicht, na ja, nee, aber es könnte natürlich gut sein. Könnte natürlich gut sein. Aber man könnte auch in die Richtung forschen, man kriegt das ja vielleicht irgendwie raus, was da passiert ist. Ja, ja, ich finde es spannend, dass obwohl wir gesagt haben, ja, wir wollen eigentlich nur ein Wochenende und eigentlich auch am liebsten nur einen Tag und am liebsten auch wieder Montags früh zurück und wir müssen schon irgendwie nicht so viel wandern und wir sind ja auch nicht bewandert und wir wollen ja auch entspannt das lösen können geschafft haben, noch einfacher zu lösen, nämlich wir haben einfach das Rätsel vorgelesen und jemand hat jetzt die Lösung gesagt. Wir wissen nicht, ob es die Lösung ist, aber es kann schon sein und ich fände es aber auch gut, wenn wir so einen Mystery-Podcast haben und jede Woche einen Fall lösen und am Ende sind es es immer die Nazis. Immer. Man weiss nicht, damals ist ein Bild verschwunden. Deswegen geht die Mystery-Show auch in Deutschland nicht, weil es immer auf Nazis hinausgeht. Ja, weil man einfach von Anfang an schon weiss, sind es Nazis. Drecksnazis, ja. Einfach immer. Alle Mysterien. Mysterien. Mysterien. Mysterien, ja. Gut, sehr gut. Use the force, noch mal noch mal richtig gefunden. Freut mich. Ach ja, ich vermisse schöne Mystery-Serie, würde ich gerne mal wieder gucken. Ja, so X-Files, so Akte X. Ja, genau. Aber X-Files, ich habe letztes Mal eine Folge X-Files geguckt. Mein Gott, ist das einottenscheche. Junge, junge, junge, junge, nicht gut gealtert.
Heieieieiei.
Heidewitzka. Man hat ja dann so,
man weiss ja, es ist ja oft so Serien,
die man in guter Erinnerung hat und man weiss nicht,
ist es wirklich eine gute Serie oder
ist es eine von diesen Katastrophenserien und
dann denkt man sich so, oh nochmal eine Folge Power Rangers
gucken kultig Grottenscheche.
Nicht mal Trashig schlecht, sondern einfach
Grottenschlecht. Auf der anderen Seite denkst du dir, geil, nochmal Madlock, immer noch geil. So, ist nun mal geil. Mark Madlock. Es gibt zwei verschiedene Serien. Mark Madlock von immer noch tollen Alben. Die ersten drei Alben, immer noch gut, die kann man immer noch anhören. Drei, oh Gott. Oh mein Gott. Aber X-Files kann man echt nicht angucken. Es ist so schlecht, es ist alles so mit der Brechstange geschrieben, wie die Leute immer den Ort wechseln müssen ohne Motivation und dann immer so diese verschiedenen Monster, der eine, der brennen kann ohne zu sterben. The Monsters of the Week. Ja, und dann immer so unmotiviert die Leute, ja dann erschiesst mich doch.
Nee, ich bin FBI-Agent, ich erschiesße dich nicht, ja aber dann werde ich stark, ja aber, mein ich, aber dann brennt alles, du denkst dir, was, woher red ich denn?
Aber die Musik ist gut.
Ja, du schaust nur die Folge, damit du am Ende den geilen Soundtrackers.
Mega.
Ist es eigentlich nur so erfolgreich wie Musik? Kann sein. Ist es ein Theremin? Ja, der wedelt da sogar vorhin. Theremins sind auch echt wahnsinnig, also obwohl sie wahnsinnig unterbewertet sind, immer noch wahnsinnig überbewertet. Aber jetzt mal eine Frage an dich. Ein Theremin ist ja, je näher man dran ist, desto höher. Und je weiter man weg ist. Aber hört man den Ton irgendwann nicht mehr, weil das Theramin keinen Ton mehr erzeugt oder weil der Ton zu tief ist für das menschliche Ohr? Das menschliche Ohr kann gut sein, tatsächlich, oder? Also dass selbst wenn man sich 20 Meter vom Theramin weit entfernt befindet, es immer noch einen Ton erzeugt, aber der so tief ist, dass sie nicht mal mehr im Maulwürfel waren. Ich habe auch Angst, dass irgendwann mal, Stichwort Optimierungsoperationen, irgendwann mal, ah okay, wir haben jetzt unbedingt einen Chip, den kannst du einsetzen ins Ohr und dann hörst du noch tausend Frequenzen tiefer und tausend Frequenzen höher. Ja. Und du machst es rein und es ist einfach der grösste Lärm der Welt. Einfach. Und du erfährst halt einfach, dass Füchse sprechen können. Ja. Halt ganz normal. Hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo, hallo. Und ich so, was? Ja, halt auf einer tiefen Frequenz. Und die können halt ganz normal dialektfreies Hochdeutsch. Die reden halt eine sehr sexy-type Stimme. Ja. Dialektfreies Hochdeutsch, teilweise manche von denen sprechen Englisch. Dürfte ich mal ganz kurz nach der Uhrzeit mich erkundigen und einfach niemand antwortet mir. Sechzehn Uhr. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Der erste Mensch, der mir antwortet. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich wünsche noch einen schönen Tag. Tschüss. Tschüss. Mach es gut. Mach es gut. Nächster, ja. Mr.te. Mr. Fox. Kann, kann gut sein.
Kann gut sein. Wo wird uns die Technik hinfinden? Wir wissen es nicht.
Vielleicht wissen wir nächste Woche mehr, wenn wir uns wieder...
Mit Sicherheit nicht, weil die Luft kann hier schon was zum Segel nehmen.
Hört auf jeden Fall wieder rein und haut rein, macht's gut.
Bis dann, wir heben ab und sagen Tschüss.
Heben ab und wünschen wir nächste Woche.
Ciao.
It's a voice by production.